The master has given you permission
to take the trial of manners again.
Let us continue.
Who the hell are you?!
Heaven's Door!
"I am the guide at the main gate."
"I am the messenger of the will
of theland."
"Those who enter here
with no respect and breach manners
will lose something they cherish."
"This is the punishment of the mountains."
"With manners, there can be no lenience."
"Gain something or lose something."
"This is the code of this land
and the power of the mountains.'
"Those who respect the land
will gainsuccess
and those who do not
will lose things one by one."
This boy is not a Stand User.
He's just a servant, a guide.
The boyhimself has no ability.
We're in a jam!
Our enemies are the mountain gods!
"She breached three rules."
"So she lost three things."
"Because she wanted to try again."
"Trying again is impudence!"
"Furthermore…
turning someone into a 'book'"
and readingtheir mind
without their permission
is an act of disrespect."
"It is bad manners!"
Oh, my God!
You gotta be kidding!
This is bad!
My… heart…
My heart… I can't…breathe…
Miss Izumi…
seems to be having a heart attack.
Mr. Rohan Kishibe…
you have broken one rule of etiquette,
so you will lose one thing.
Is she going to die?
So…
would you like to try again,
or are yougoing to go home now?
No way. No way I can go home now!
I beg you, have mercy on her.
She just wanted to be happy. That's all.
She thought it'd be good research
for my work.
She was just being a good editor.
With manners, there can be no lenience.
Gain something or lose something.
How should you eat this corn?
Will you try again,Mr. RohanKishibe?
Or will you go home for today?